I would say for me I don't understand
how you do something halfway I did that
through high school and doing that I saw
the I saw the instant consequence you
know there was a moment where after high
school where my friends went on and they
started going to college and I was a guy
who didn't even know do we apply I
didn't know when I was applying to
college or in a job I thought it was
playing all this time we were y'all gone
what was a joke to me was never a joke
to anybody else I was the only one that
the joke was being played to one so when
I thought we were hooking or cutting
class well I thought we all weren't
gonna work I thought we all were we're
getting by in just [ __ ] off
opportunities oh it's just me Oh y'all
been doing your work this whole time
oh [ __ ] huh Wow University of University
of University of I was the only jackass
I was going to Community College that's
not to take a shot at anybody that's
going to Community College because those
colleges are available for a reason I
was doing jackass and didn't have a plan
because I thought that was a cool thing
to do so I saw what not working hard got
me I didn't take my SAT I did an
advocate dad but going down and guessing
at it because I thought that's what we
all were doing because we were hooking
in class to go I was the only [ __ ]
then did it the other way so that joke
was on me that to me that was an
eye-opener man well if I'm gonna do
something I should never do a half way
and that means that if I didn't want to
do it that way you shouldn't do it and
I'm not gonna do it to show what I can
do it the best my business then why am i
doing it if you ask me to come work out
what you're not gonna work out and I
[ __ ] to work out while I'm gonna
work out if you ask me to come see a
movie and I go to sleep and
like get in there well why don't I go to
the movie why don't I just say I want to
stay home if you ask me to go and get up
early with you so we can go look at
these these apartments or our housing
complexes and I get down there and it's
got a negative attitude why the [ __ ] did
I go what I've learned and how I operate
is that you're in so much control of
yourself that it's ridiculous and
sometimes it's easy to put out excuses
for yourself that makes sense to you we
all know the [ __ ] truth we all know
if we're giving a hundred percent of
every night we all know you tell me go
outside and pick up the dog [ __ ] my wife
tell me every morning I don't want to go
out there and pick the dog [ __ ] but I
get up and do it if I go out there and I
take two steps and I'm like minutes to
early I'll do this [ __ ] later then that
means that I'm [ __ ] I'm I'm already
he compromising an action that I said I
was going to do that I'm not if I say I
want to do something I'm gonna do it if
I don't say it don't expect it from me I
never put my foot in my mouth well why
do you expect me to go do that I never
said I would do that that's the one
power that I have that's the one thing
that can never be taken from me what I
say I'm going to do I do and if I do do
something that puts me in a position to
be scolded because my actions weren't
correct then I gotta stand up and I
gotta say that too hey I said I was
gonna do XYZ I didn't do it I gotta wear
that hat hit me with the stupid stick at
a dummy head scold me whatever you gotta
do I [ __ ] up I allowed said that I
would do and I did Tibet I'm wrong
that's the difference that's what I'm
okay with I'm okay with standing and
[ __ ] smelling it if I have to I'm
trying my best to avoid it but I'm not
perfect
so there's ever a moment where that
happens and it has to happen though
I morning but as I've gotten older my
words become more of my bond take care
of me I want you to come talk to these
kids man look it's a group of kids me
hey I can't do that I'm not because of
the kids I'm tired it's fine another
time where I can
there was a time back in the day kept
on-top said yeah I forgot that you can't
get me on the phone well why did I say I
could do it I've learned from that I
don't I don't play those games so if I
say you're gonna get me you're gonna get
100% of me if I don't [ __ ] I can then
I'm not gonna say
you